So when going to a networking event,
I think you want to come up with
at least a couple of things.
First, if there's content in this event,
you want to learn at least one thing
that's relevant for your business.
And so you want to go to a networking
event that you can hopefully learn
something relevant for you.
But the most important thing
is trying to figure out
specific individuals there that
would be good for your business.
Are there other investors
that can help you?
Are you looking for a co-founder?
It's really about trying to tell
your story in a very succinct way,
so the person across from you
will understand what you do and
hopefully connect.
I think it's not about quantity,
it's really about quality.
Don't try to shake hands with 100
different people for one second.
Try to find those five, six,
seven people that there's a chance
that they will dramatically influence
the trajectory of your startup.
Because they join you as an employee,
or as an investor, or
perhaps connect you to
somebody who can be that.